Hello and welcome to the final video in our series here and I've entitled this
Where To Next. I'm hoping with this to give you some sort of jump off points
if you're looking to do something sort of more complicated with Python. So to start with,
do remember you can take and expose your own code from C++. This is going to allow you to do a hell
of a lot more. So the whole power and functionality that comes with C++ you can expose the functions
and then have the ease and accessibility to write quick code and embed them in other places.
Now there are some limitations it does support blueprints read and write and blueprint read
only blueprint callable blueprint pure getters and setters and native makes and breaks and
what's to be said for pure though it's not it converts it into a a normal non-pure function
so just be aware of that. We do not support blueprint internal use only and custom thunk
functions. Next up running headless editor versions with Python scripts.
Now everything we've been doing up to this point has been within the editor. Now it is
possible to run Python scripts and run them against unreal without actually firing up the
editor you can actually fire it up in a headless mode. Now it's tricky and I've had real problems
getting it to function how I expected it to work however there is a great article out on
the developer community which talks about running it with PowerShell script so do check that out.
If you find that the documentation that's out there is a little bit lacking there are
a few good articles which I really recommend especially if you're working with the specific
part of the engine for example the sequencer python cookbook is a great guide on how to use
code and gives you a bunch of examples if you're looking to play around with sequencer which is
also how we edit and create videos and then there are a couple of good ones if you're looking
to animate or using ik retargeting and if you're looking to use rigging and control rig so
do you can search for any of these and they'll come up you should be able to find them within
Google and that will bring them and thank you for sticking with us through this entire set of
videos I hope you find this really useful and go on to create some fantastic python scripts
thank you very much goodbye